okay all right everyone Thanks for uh
coming this is the last the last session
of Pi data 2022 so here in your city so
thanks for hanging around
or else you didn't go outside to the
Rain hi everyone thanks
so I'm going to talk about actually uh
practical ml Ops uh so loaded to worry
we'll try to unbox it a bit and kind of
talk about how I've actually uh first
problem
so first I want to walk through a
traditional ml kind of mainly highlight
the issues
you know who's done actually and no one
here find those those issues so there'll
be some extra resonating with you
um oh then I'll talk about a subset of
them on opposite is actually what I
think is important
to address and moving ml to a production
and then I'll walk through a complete
example it's small but it's kind of but
I should contrived but it still touches
all the points uh that I think are
important and
doing a production there now
so there are some files for this if you
want to download them they're on my
actually GitHub most laptops can't see
this because it's actually gonna have
in the camera but you can
take a picture of this you know an
inflator but uh this has uh the data set
which is actually small but uh and some
other things that are actually
supporting
and so
my main goals are to basically um
basically I need to show to my
unit managers uh the ROI for actually
doing ml right and in doing that uh
getting a handle on how much time we
spend doing experiments
you can't just go off you know like you
used to be able to do this and you go up
for a month or two and then you have to
say oh yeah it's hard right but uh we've
actually gone past that now and um other
parts are getting a hold of the data
source of artifacts that you actually
build and transform along the way
model reproucibility because sometimes
if the vacuum buildings again change
things tune things
um once you know way back it was
actually new is to kind of get away with
things now people have actually had
models in production for years and so
you need to be able to have that con
continuity
and um kind of also kind of a high level
thing but basically getting timelines
down for when you say I'm going to do
this in actually two months
getting some sort of way to manage that
make it easier so that you can actually
predict things a little bit better
um
my ml requirements are a little bit
different than prior house here
um I actually do ml based technology for
introducing
a detection on aircraft and tanks and
anything that moves really
um so my uh I my work is very embedded
and so I have uh once it ships like
like a shift it's gone like it may not
come back for months actually and so
um it it's probably very different than
what people usually do with actually
MMOs they put up in the cloud and they
can change them really easily so this is
kind of changed how I actually worked it
also a small team is me I'm the only
person that does in my company uh so
I am hiring too uh
so
and also of course open source we all
love it because
um
I need the code
and so
way back this was all you ever did with
actually
yeah ml you basically get your data
build your model and then you throw it
over the fence over the years we've
actually realized that it's probably the
best idea and so mlops has come up as
the ultimate answer for everything
and um
I won't be addressing all of the picture
of envelops but uh
MLS ml as you can see here uh and if I
know that has its ownership set of
unique challenges
so one of the biggest ones actually
these are all about I've
11 issues and they're all about equally
the same and um you know it's a very
extreme driven you process and uh so you
have to basically iterate and which is
actually fine
um I think that's fine but but it gets a
little hard when uh you keep on doing
you know iterations and uh keeping track
of what you know what I said you're on
where you're at uh what was the action
you had prior run all those things
um they're fine when you're doing your
graduate work uh but when you have to
actually ship things and people want to
know where you're at everything it's
hard to manage if it's all written down
and so being able to keep track of where
you are in the experimental
data process
is a problem reproducibility is probably
one of the biggest ones uh we've all
seen these things where not just to
actually
ml but it comes to highlight a lot you
know when you have action models that
work well on your laptop but then they
don't work on someone else's action
machine or they when you ship it it
doesn't work the way you thought it did
so it gets kind of hard to manage mainly
because you have uh
identity problems and data problems and
all these things kind of come in that
make your uh fun
uh traceability being able to basically
uh you have this uh a model that you
come up with actually and uh if it's
great you know fine but what was the
what were the uh processes that you took
it through what was the uh parameters
for tuning it uh what actually uh were
the uh data that you actually finally
got after you went through it and
managed it for a while so all those
things actually uh it doesn't just the
end model is the whole entire chain that
you want to have
and related to that of course is data
versioning you have this thing in the
end that you end up with that you train
your model on but it wasn't what you
were actually given or
from the field
I usually have to take it and transform
it clean up a bit
examine it you figure out like for what
I do I have tons of data in the
petabytes and I don't I can't use all of
it so I have to take substance of it and
I archive those things but it gets to
feel it's it's hard okay
model
versioning this is fine when you have
version 1.0 and you ship it but once
that ships and then you have the 2.0 and
you have something over here that uses
actually 1.0 knowing how to go back and
change model 1.0
can be challenging because the person
who wrote that could be gone now
the data that you had was lost
but anyhow there's all kinds of problems
with getting the right action model that
you had and being which you can
basically go back and figure out what
was
making effect
oversight
is kind of another another facet
um usual software engineering you have
um your team lead to look at your code
and uh you know say what are you doing
here or you know why aren't you using
this actually this API or that in ml
office are kind of left to our own even
if we have our own groups actually you
can kind of Go off into the weeds and so
this makes it kind of
the culture isn't there actually first
off
but having
um
having an easy way to come in and look
at some awesome stuff
um is a necessary point I think
and related to that is testing we all
love to test our code
my company's on this test driven
development thing now which is kind of
new
York it came back from the it was
actually back in the dead it was back in
1996 it started so all things are coming
back
artifacts related to the data earlier uh
this is more along the lines of not just
data and model but all those pieces that
come in between that uh if you're doing
a complicated NLP model you may have
dictionaries of you know words that are
actually good you may have all these
things along the way that are uh are
important in building the model but they
aren't I mean may not be the only things
that you need but uh they want to help
you figure things out
and logging this is not such a big thing
but um
usually at least when you're doing it
the first time it's usually a manual
manual process and building anything and
even the smallest things can be actually
you know automated but when they get
more and more complicated logging is um
it's not so easy to do when you have a
lot of pieces that are actually moving
around
model refreshes uh this is once you've
actually deployed it you have some
issues with model you have where you
want to get better accuracy and certain
insert aspects
uh this gets a little tied to kind of um
going back
and being able to pull out the tree of
things that you actually did and do it
again and so if it's uh very manual or a
person that was actually doing that
before is now on a different project and
you have to go and take it you have to
go back and figure out what he or she
did and it's like real pain to figure
out like what that you're actually doing
here
um that makes it really hard and also in
that point it gets really it makes makes
it very hard for
me as a manager to be able to have the
confidence that I have the same thing
that was you know I had the same type of
coverage that we did before
and the final one is consistency
um
like I said it's the first one it's fine
when you have 10 of them and you have
things that are shipping at different
rates some actually customers are more
important so you have
to focus on them uh but having project
consistency is really uh core and of
course the cookie cutter data science
thing is really nice header of course is
actually based on that
tree of
border structures so it's nice but
having that is really very important I
think
so signs that you may have some problems
in your ml workflow and these are just
things that I've seen uh
and things that I've actually done
basically get long ramp up times so you
get a new thing and then all of a sudden
you have to take a lot of time to figure
out how to get going again
um technical debt you have code over
here over here how do you
you I share things that have been done
before
can I easily reproduce models that
you're asked to
and also scaling issues and this is
usually not technical wise people-wise
how to STL people how can you use people
more effectively especially when you
have a tiny team it gets kind of hard to
be able to actually take on too much
work um you have a lot of individual you
know snowflake projects where you have
to kind of do everything over again
so
in one Ops at the high level is probably
one of the most overused terms uh we've
ever had to actually encounter and it
still hasn't solve everything
um in short though we're trying to
basically take models from your laptop
and put them into wherever you consider
a production right and uh that hard that
that that part is uh what the in office
trying to solve right and the largest
part of that is not getting it out there
the first time it's maintaining it two
years later that is when it's really
hard because
you I don't remember things from my six
uh you know six weeks ago you let alone
two uh two years ago what I did
technically on a certain action uh
a project
and
Loft doesn't have to be so
big and complicated and hire a team of
people to manage your feature stores and
your
model uh model observability all those
things you don't have to have all those
pieces which is what I'm going to get to
like you know these guys Uber and Google
and so on uh they have a lot of things
going on they have people at teams are
dedicated doing to doing these kind of
things and
but my point is you don't even have that
to get a lot of value out of this
so
kind of the components I see
two envelopes you have uh kind of this
chain of things from data ingestion
pipelines this is a
modeling and maybe outside here we get
smaller whatever and it's not a problem
and monitoring I don't know if anyone
really that monitors their own models
but that's a thing too and uh
today though I'm not going to talk about
all these things I want to talk about
four things here
the data ingestion part is data sets
like CC files
um Jason files I.E deal with tons of
blobs of data coming from action
vehicles
um
the cool part here is basically a bunch
of python code and that's uh
Pedro
and
all right trees I use ml flow very
simple thing to do okay
today but it's very important part that
is simple to actually address I think
and my appointment is actually kind of
a kind of small
and monitoring is actually it's embedded
so talking about kedro
uh it's an open source framework it's
been around for a bit uh
it's really
defined by a bunch of nodes and
pipelines and those nodes are what do
the work and pipelines are what you
chain those nodes together to actually
do larger pieces of effort
and
um
so the sequencing part is cool
so here we're going to talk about a uh
the work we're trying to do is actually
a anomaly detection
and I have a temperature data set right
there
and we're going to build an isolation
Force
as our core machine learning model
and who in here wants to go to go along
with this or who wants to just actually
watch
I don't know how much work that needs to
be done
okay good
so
let's get ready then
um
I don't know who likes
uh pionev versus anaconda but let's
first actually uh create a new
environment
and everyone needs any help actually
I'll be happy to help just uh just yell
let's make this as interactive as
possible so everyone kind of get this
because this is not a very complicated
thing and I want everyone to understand
it uh and my option all these things I'm
talking about don't have to be really
hard to uh to get into it is a bit kind
of some things to learn and there's a
lot of with our great things but in the
end I think um this is really a good
example to actually get your head into
and then um the packages we use foreign
starts
I don't usually start here this is
actually kind of cheap but I usually
tweak around a little bit and then I go
like this once I figured out what up I
want to do but this is where I would
then start using git right from the
actual actual gaming so the repo
everything is basically action version
um because all of the things that you're
going to have those artifacts are going
to be part of kedro or in this basically
tree down
okay
anything but two seven
any words I've used uh three seven I
think it was the lowest I've used
foreign
and so um
and for this
once you have this point
uh
and that's where you just type in a name
that's all you do and then after that
you're done
I'm joking
so Kendra knew actually let me just show
you here
let's actually
is
everyone see this
I'm increasing yeah
yeah so um
when you do kedro new and you give it a
name
what's interesting here
four actually five
five paths that are really really
important actually
data pointers it'll be your uh
chemo base
so he'll point to the different textures
of Paths of data that you have
to do whatever
all the code is and they'll be broken
into pipelines and nodes
and uh
in dots are what you create so
that you really
have to creating
code
open up so this will make you fight more
and maybe
because the laws are good to look at to
see what they want
your errors and things will be there
so
they can actually do it on their own
that's great and they can share things
but I don't want
the books it's hard to
a collaboration with grants to run
together margin just makes it hard
great concept just for execution
but now this is how it looks
no no it's actually um it is created
when it is created is to uh it shows all
the ignore
these are all the things that it
actually creates this
Pedro does this new when you do it it
knows what you're going to be doing so
you can add your things but I tend to be
very uh
a pedestrian in my usage of this so
it just works well
as well so one of the core things to
Pedro is making you think about your
data and how you organize accessing it
and
the catalog is I think one of the basic
concepts is if all this if all you don't
get out of this is any more than than
the catalog
is cool
then I'll have one but keeping track of
your
everyday even though it sounds easy when
you have three or four
eight projects that going on at the same
time you have uh people working at
different rates uh junior people and
senior people and it's like it gets
really hard to understand where people
are and things and so getting an
organization around your data and the
usage of that is very very important and
so
into the catalog which is basically
top face of the event and base actually
like
catalog file is vml file and it has all
kinds of things in here for this example
we have a
inmates never went out
putting on the other type
excuse me file and
file tax and this is all relative to the
tree that we ran actually and so if you
go up over here parallel to the top it's
actually potato and so under data is a
whole bunch of things you can actually
get from cookie cutter zero one zero two
zero three and there's raw process and
it's good to keep those names I think
it's good to think about things in terms
of what stage you're at
and so
uh this goes by the way
on the site I don't know who's in here
is working on this actively right now
but uh on the site that I had linked
actually there's a uh a couple emo files
that have this already typed up so you
just copy and paste if you want
and also there's other things that go
into this this right here isn't just
your
so this is up uh other things you add to
the catalog are your output like your
intermediate points like if you want to
save your test files that you actually
create on the way most things are
basically
kept in memory and this actually allows
you to say if you put things in here you
can
that basically allows you to have uh
snapshots of the data that you have ran
and just for a relationship you can
always write
your environment and everything uh you
can easily see things in the catalog
that are earnings of trees
and like in mind the final one
so this is actually
kind of along the way
but
I've actually already defined uh they
look like
so this is kind of like
the first part here
I know and then you can actually have
a completely eBay
database
and there's a whole bunch of extensible
uh that you can actually and there's
okay
how those images
and other things SVG
um
anything that you want to write code for
you can do it because it's pretty easy
yeah so the cookie cutter is uh I
haven't used it for ages but it was
basically you I started out and you give
it a name and then it just would do kind
of like what this actually does but it
doesn't have any of the code around it
the faces there's your data your input
your output and all the different stages
of the uh ml price ml processing that
you would go to manually
and so it kind of addressed the points
or a couple points I had in terms of
consistency
early on I talked about being able to
come in and know where things are
that's kind of what it actually I
started out you know to actually do
uh it's a there's a whole bunch of code
around it we'll get through a little bit
here
it uh allows you to create these nodes
and pipelines and the uh nodes are the
processing actions that happen on the
data that you defined that you'd be in
the cook cutter uh tree right where you
might have some input it's an output
um and then the pipeline is how you want
to go through the operations you want to
First do this then do this and this then
that should put the model then I save it
here and so on
yeah yep yeah
yeah
I'm not sure about that actually file
yeah I see project here
yeah
Yep this is where the action action name
is defined that you put in there
I've never used this other than uh the
actual name if you change the name uh
that's where you change that and the
versioning of
the actual uh of the actual project
but I'm not used
okay
um
so we have the catalog
defining without actually one entry
right and it points to the easy file you
can also run the uh
be different that was actually loaded
this is mainly for just between I don't
use as much but it's like there's if you
have some some extra problems it's kind
of nice to be able to have
kind of so now getting into pipelines
this is um
not necessarily cookie cutter type
things but it's good to name things the
same way like every project I always
have I always have
a few
times
but it's good to have the same names
and it's it's uh yeah just pick it a
convention and stick with it
so first thing you would basically do
and this is to create the uh first line
of action which would be the data is
your increase
right
uh don't all things d e
a country and uh it does make offense to
us before
I mess you'll see it especially created
and then so that's the first
um
node a pipeline and then the data
highest peace is the next one
and so both those two are together you
should be able to see inside of the uh
pipeline
subjects
okay
and I say you should see three years
too because I did have another part of
this
but it went too long
all right so now here's where we
actually get some work done
um this is
um
I have a file here
okay good okay so I have the supporting
file on GitHub and also locally here I
can show you but so there's the data
engineering aspect we're going to
basically take what we defined in the
catalog and we're going to base all we
do is going to exploit it
that's a train now
actually this whole example can probably
be done in 30 lines of code so it's
if you grow into a large project it
would it would that's a little basically
you know the same yeah my action plan
and code but so the node node
this is gonna be where all the action
happens on data coming again and data
coming out
the pipeline is going to Define all
those functions as nodes so you can
actually then organize them in some
other way okay
and once you have find
code and then I'll show you how it looks
actually
so for the
this is basically right there
you have more than a trained pets splits
so that it is actually fine
so that's my they have work there
and
then you could
you could take this and actually just
run
but only after you defined uh
pipeline which is right
so this is the pipeline code
and so remember node is the actual code
that does the work and the pipeline is
how you hook it up
and then the name of this code
but you might do
it's good to have a connection
s
of course but you won't figure out what
your career
so once you have to find that
excuse just that node which will then
execute the uh sorry
I don't need
everyone everyone fine
so I want to show you how it looks
actually
this might be a little bit too much
because I have actually defined
um
so this is actually with both data
engineering and data science pipelines
done
so
you just actually defined
the data method
and then you have the training
training goes into our change the actual
Au model
output is the pictures
actually
that's the prediction
yeah
and so this is basically
and
what what yellow is
I'm going to talk about this this you
can add a lot of parameters to these uh
to these actually nodes and these
functions
like
so
you can actually pull out
things and uh these actually uh in if I
use that you want to pass in
and uh be able to
you check of all those uh a parameters
this actually like the information
factor is in a file
that is actually
in the comp base parameters Dot yaml
is contamination Factor right there and
so if you have any
things you want to uh to keep in terms
of the project going through and these
are the things that you would actually
tweak the news is where you would put
them at instead of putting it into code
right you would put them in here and
then
in the
Community Information
of the model there and then
in the
data science pipeline that looks like
this actually
find a note
that gets pulled in from the actual
animal file so
instead of passing things around in
functional form
parameters you know file
right now yeah
with over there right now
so um I can't talk about this right here
part this is the data science part that
you went ahead and did
um
yeah
and so this is on the
parameters
Factor we go into the top big
dynamophile
as
a small less than one or so
and to answer your question about
bringing this all together
you need to these individual pipelines
make sense by themselves and they should
be able to be ran independently but what
you want to do and what I was uh showing
from the web
using our face there shows everything
all together and that is done by
basically the pipeline registry
which is actually
this and
this how it looks right there
comp base parameters I always err on
adding things here because uh if you
hard go thing which is always kind of
fun and easy but I uh it's easier to do
this
up front if you know what you're going
to be treating usually if you've done
things before right you know you know
certain models need certain parameter
points to tweak and so uh I would add
them here
so then registering the pipeline
which looks like this actually
basically
yes here and then
foreign
just an actual Diagon of nodes uh that
it walks to create the trees to execute
and also to actually show
how things look
in this form
it's not hard
foreign
thank you yeah
everyone loves yaml
until you have to use it
came up with yourself
that should that's how it should look
right here
let me know if that doesn't help
and so then
this is actually the uh Pipeline and to
be honest this is not the most useful
thing you can't do much with this other
than that show it off to its managers
which actually does help
um but
I guess it's a good thing to uh have to
be able to pull up what a project did
and be able to point out that this is
where I did a bunch of code like that
was like this because the hardest part
of ml
projects is that you end up doing things
over and over again and if you think
about things well enough
in terms of getting this into a
structure you know that makes sense once
we'll probably end up doing it again
just to wear a lot of the actual value
here is
and then
um
I'm gonna show this
uh is yours working fine now
okay I'll I'll help you there
uh Kendra run
basically runs through everything and it
logs things to the log file and so
um I love the actual warnings here
there's an ICC
just feudals having its versions of
being done and so on but
you have basically a lot yeah
slow yourself from this it's actually
running this node it's doing data here's
where it goes it's saving data in here
um these work and hopefully actually 500
support and use the catalog right and
you add things to the catalog they get
matched and then they basically get
saved off
um
and
you're training you can take off another
model too and this is where I would use
mlflow to actually eat a version the uh
the action models that you make
and then um
when it's done
with the running
prediction here that data is being saved
Android that goes out into the output so
then basically I have a whole trip from
input to Output
okay
and so you can also just want to
what we just did so if you only want to
run the data engineering side of things
to say clean data or something you can
just actually run that and
exactly easiest to do that because
that's kind of how you can get into
using it as a tool that you've already
done you've done the you get a very
complicated chain there
a processing you could use that chain on
other things other uh other
if that's cheap to Define them
in the catalog
and uh
so now
next you could do is kedro package which
would package everything you had up and
then make it into so you could install a
pip
um
I have done a little bit of this and
it's really interesting it is kind of
there's not an easy way to basically put
this out there but it is
your work's done in a sense that you
package it up so that it's easy for
someone like a a devops extra person to
actually handle this and you could
actually walk them through it how to
actually uh how to use it also a bunch
of other things like building docks
which is good to have ground and uh you
can make sure that
by doc uh duct strings in their code
and so
overall like um we've actually attacked
some of the problems this is not consult
all the mops issues uh but the biggest
thing that I need is actually
reproducibility can I take something and
reboot it six months from now
can I build something and then actually
take pieces of that and use it and and
other actual projects so
modularity I think a lot of that comes
from actually just thinking about things
right and you're breaking out the actual
problem when you're doing the data
engineering side of things how do you
process that
uh maintaining ability
obviously you have to do this stuff for
an actual job so uh you need to have
people wait they're not going to be
around for a while you need to be able
to actually plan for that hopefully you
have a nice uh company that you know
makes people happy so they actually want
to say uh but that's always the case and
so it's kind of uh nice to have
a project that you can can actually get
into and know where things are
again
versioning so
versioning is not
explicit here though it's it's in the
catalog and so this this actually does
address what data was used to build
model X
it doesn't say that's version 1.0 of the
file
always so the version is more of an
implied thing but I think knowing which
data was used is oh I need if you want
to have version 1.2 of this then there's
uh the cookie cutter actually paths
where you would have intermediate steps
is where you would Define catalog and
catalog entries for infinite data
Crossing steps that you want to have
artifacts held around for
um documentation and packaging
is it kind of light but you know it is I
mean that you get
um
you can easily doctrines by yourself but
it's kind of harder in the ml sense to
have everything making sense
um so the docs are good and packaging
does help there's lots of ways if you
look on the ketro site there's a lot of
different ways you can uh basically
plug this into other things and have it
work
and so if you want to use use kedro
um by the way this was a forcing
function for me to actually do some of
the work I've been doing and so it was
kind of I've been wanting to get into
this and I used this as a I have to give
a talk on this so I have to actually I I
actually I actually had to kind of come
to grips with I need to make my email
stuff not be like how I've done it
before in the past and so I need to be
able to actually grow the group and so
on and I need to have everyone coming in
knowing what's going on and so this is
kind of me kind of bringing in what am I
going to do and so I covered a whole
any projects that I did to this and
worked out great uh almost as
complicated as this but it had a lot
more code in the nodes of course but
um
um it was pretty pretty good and so
that's I want to hire other people and
do other things I want to do the same
type of thing and just keep on doing
that so that I I can kind of know where
you know know where we are and because
we actually do ship things that
are going to be out of vehicles that are
hopefully going to keep people you know
safe and so on so I need to be able to
actually take those that uh take the uh
those models and maintain them for years
to come because those actually contracts
from either there you know for years to
come so
it's very fun and uh so but anyhow I
think the hardest part is
basically I mean not sticking with it
don't quit say or don't find other
things that are shiny and go oh that
looks nice and start over there
and so um
yeah
but it's a pretty good extra framework
um it's not that's everything there's a
lot of issues you'll find that are kind
of it's actually you know boilerplate
stuff you have to to actually deal with
but it's still it's once you get
actually used to it it's a pretty handy
and then some resources this talk will
be on the GitHub site along with all of
the data and uh this is it and actually
mark down so I'll have a PDF and this
will be there this is the actually PDF
and the markdown will be there and then
these are the links uh so things mlop
site which has all the pretty pictures
of how things look and uh at big
companies uh the kedro uh
provide you actual model new Ash
versioning uh you might want to use
Neptune to do things
um which is uh nothing.ai which is a
cloud service for people that can access
clouds
I can't do that stuff but um kind of
nice to be able to
um
put your code certain points to be able
to
basically know
makes nice chart settings you can
actually figure out what's going on
um
and then again if you only
during the whole hell of action uh
as a half dose I guess
and try to issue one a lot of these
things into that but
that's it
[Applause]
did you get everything working
good
any questions
yeah far away
yeah I would
yeah
so I would
it
I haven't dealt with this yet to the
problem but my my problems are very
much the same but also at the same time
I'm probably a person in the next
differently so I will have some shared
code so
I I would probably stick with
having its own thing each project has
its own thing until you get to a point
where you have a lot of of shared things
uh if you can have a shared pipeline
then there's a way to do kedro export I
think pipelines you can actually export
things
I kind of like independent things uh
mainly because I think a lot of times I
work on problems that are like they'll
change a lot like I'm working on one
aircraft now that is a very different
thing than the other ones that I've done
and so it looks you know very different
and I'm gonna solve it with a different
way and so I'm gonna have a lot of code
that's totally new
and so that doesn't answer your question
so much but it
yeah yeah
and it doesn't it kind of makes it
Badness Institute because you could have
a point where you have code that looks
the same running in two different places
and then you're like you update one they
have to go up to the other and you have
the whole the whole entire mess that
we've tried to solve right
um
I think then
I would probably reorganize it to be
one project if it had a lot of shared
functionality
but I would
grow with her for a while and try to
figure out if it works and you know
those kind of things will be interesting
because there are some people that have
talked about it online how to do that
kind of stuff
and uh
yeah I think uh the biggest part is it
makes me more aware of uh structure and
testing of things so that I can I do
have a lot of we have these things
that's called a
Hill Hardware
in the loop and um basically all of uh
like we have this tank that basically is
all the pieces that are of the tank all
the driving pieces but not the extra
tank itself and so you can actually
but the hardware I mean the software in
there and actually did actually a lot of
testing
um so this kind of makes it easier to
test more and more often I think any
other way I would do it I'd probably do
the same thing you know it's a Cron job
it runs whenever it can and you have us
you know CI CD stuff that does things
with air and it's
I think the biggest part is that you
have testing is kind of a little bit
actually easier and you can hand it off
to someone else and they'll know how to
access it if they're
they're on your team
I think
that's about it I think
yeah so this can plug into into airflow
there's things you can do with it but I
need to have an open source answer to
things I wouldn't have code that I could
actually take off from here to submit
when we go to the FAA and have to have
our rsf has to be and here's all the
code that runs on myself
those people need to then be also
certified
so
yeah
um
this actually creates some git ignore
the whole things that are contained okay
and I just use that okay I I do I'm
working on some Dosa and I added some
things to go
foreign
uh would like not to take down the not
to run your pipeline how do they access
both their aspect of the world
yeah so that is
where you have common server
um I like have uh people I I do work now
I went there to run the code on their
own thing and use item uh I had a trip
that brings everything up actually so
that is insults that he has a high-end
so that basically it's all but it's
actually checking in should work and
create the same time
this is kind of a fun question for a
catering versus other three months and
uh
when I think about jumbo versus Flash
um cater Road it's more example it's a
big grammar it's kind of opinionated
introduces structure but the downside is
um it's gonna be hard to migrate
and then there's not a
just a little bit
uh that's it I think it's not it's it's
updated and it's a structure that the
data is there and I think the hardest
part is if you do
anything else you have to copy out the
code from the nodes and put it into
something that looks like the pipeline
that you actually find
um that's not that complicated I think
but uh if you ever want to move out it
will be that hard but I don't know what
you would do too because
the things that I've seen out there like
uh there's ml flow there's some things
but you know it's very very lightweight
uh to put
what this says
yeah
but hopefully uh I tend to I used to uh
I was younger Asian who went online this
is shiny this is
because if it works
but now I have uh yeah you know
customers that need half action figures
actually they're working I need to make
sure
there's a problem
[Music]
have you tried bringing in and outflow I
have yes yeah hey where do where does
that come in yeah
there's a package on GitHub it's called
Pedro it actually can offload it kind of
bring two together and so basically
uh this activity
and it will keep actually good versions
I'm using seoi
okay excellent TV Works in there and I
don't have an excellent server too
the things are going out but
it does make a little hardcore hand job
is actually remember prior to
180. it's like oh yeah
come on
we just got away we're just supposed to
like these days
on the rules from like the actual data
center yeah so I've done both pipe test
is fine I think that's really good for
for little things but system level
things I would Define actually
um an actual pipeline to do things okay
and so you can actually if you remember
the nodes that you already wrote right
you can actually just reference those
and say I want to pull in this note to
load a file and then transform it do not
want to run through this
um you know you can do that I mean just
I think it's really good to get into the
mindset of writing your notes
independent of
and so I think that um you do that your
test becomes pretty easy to do
and uh also reusability is like you
you've already focused like this before
right like this
the same thing happened so you end up
being able to pull things out really
easily
[Music]
and so I did take out the extra extra
python because I was like
uh but I think we have a good points
um
that he wasn't
header was used in general and he
actually talked about doing the clock
but yeah yeah this is easy install yeah
yeah
I'm not gonna change anything to the
course right now
because it seems like having my concerns
more to teaching people who are becoming
fresh on and how to get started doing
work and providing some sort of class
structure with that and I also feel like
if I work I don't think nobody's going
to give up
their hands
well I think there's a there's a point
when people
I think that the books are nice and
they're right kind of interact with
others and do it through ideas but when
you want to to shift code it's just that
there's no place for that I mean like it
has to be like I do I actually get I
have to give actually models to the team
and age converts to something else right
and so it's like it gets really hard and
you know you have to have code that it's
going outside yeah would know what an
action notebook is better than a bunch
of paper right they wouldn't know what
it is and so I think
is all is nice time for people to grow
up and move off your code move out of
their books and then work over here and
it's good it's good to keep it though
yeah I just don't want people working on
marketing aggregate committing things
and notebooks
because just like it's people have well
I well
it's time to work
I guess Netflix
CLI maybe because they couldn't get
people throughout their books
Checker who does supporting you just
tossing yourself and it works that I'm
like I just kind of back weight and that
really really solid thank you okay
yeah
anything else yeah how could you compare
this to Emerald's clothes because you
know you're you mentioned enough
I'm not attracting or other things so I
think the project is trying to do
something yeah I haven't used it
let's see that's the easy answer but
there are pieces of of actually are also
good
the richest part is really good income
uh but like I was saying before it's
like hey pick one and stick with it uh I
think they both have
their ways of doing things
and they do make a lot of
you know which you dig into it it's good
to kind of be with them to work with it
tree I haven't actually dealt with it
and I I probably won't
[Music]
um have you thought about like data
versioning and have you ever described
any tools because there's so many like
uh you know
I don't think they're you're not
something
yeah
I'm I'm still old school on that and I
usually have data that I I have a name
in the file like where it came from and
it's like kind of it's near diverse
things and
I I know where it actually came from but
then once it gets into my hands I go
through and I I version apply basically
creating
points like fighting a training test set
I would
so I go back and he's like you know know
what I stream on
um
but I don't do any automatically working
I think that'd be kind of I'd be a
little bit extra nervous yeah
a version I think if you do keep it in
your hit uh some data that governance
issues there kind of like uh can be not
hard but uh
um textile increase it simply if it even
changed
for when they change right
like it's not hard if you have outside
the yeah okay that's a good point it
doesn't
it depends on the
type of however it's happening
Elijah yeah
yeah that's why yeah I enjoy this is
like being able to you go through a
whole bunch of stuff right and you
finally have a lot of works for the
United
how did you get to that point yeah and
then you have to trace that you're
looking at the notebooks and you're like
I don't know what happened to this you
just one point how do I get to that
point
it's actually easy so yeah this is why I
think having
a framework behind you
to help you
because as you get older sometimes you
forget what it is
I blame the kids
I think this is
oh yeah yeah
it's like
check the files in
to just like a back-end store
with your other file store and you can
check it out
and be charging for you more to get you
know the way back up if you want to use
it hello
t-shirts foreign
[Music]
so Brian do we really need all the
things yeah oh
yeah it's it's interesting because you
you created an Ops uh papers at a bigger
companies like they have all these
feature swords
there's so many things and I know
there's a lot of companies in the
humanities it all to make sense for uh
for certain type of problem but I mean I
have petabytes a data and I'm not
processing it right now for a week it's
like it's over periods of time that are
you know on your ears and I'm not active
at having to take all those hits or
whatever right now and so all those
feature stores and things um
you can actually manage that
yeah but not new selection
s overhead
and hired one of these things to do this
like uh it's full of protection much
eyesight's work on I had a better device
that is
real time but it's pretty lightweight it
can't be too big it can't be too big
so I don't have a big huge action
problem like some in my modified
I'm just curious and uh if you can feel
like what is the economic process
defense industry because um
lots of paperwork
of
experience of ago to uh to operate and
they always think that it takes months
right yeah it's like
pretty well everything is involved and
it probably has to be you have to know
how it is done and be able to have
checks everywhere
because
yeah it's a mess yeah
um
yeah yeah
I think that the defense is quite hard
yeah I've seen both sides
the defenses while online so I don't
know
two points yeah there's a also I mean
like you know when you get things
certified for actually big and across
aircraft it takes their league
years to get a box
to be a certified flying in 737 there
it's good
you want that but it is a lot of
function you work to get in there the
first time let's look absolutely
trainings it's like
hey your side but still like I have to
create like Phi with a pliers three
months and then like security because
maybe three months and stuff yeah
yeah
and if you uh ever afraid when you fly
pray any land
thank you
[Music]